- That's yours.
- This is mine.
- Look at that.
(audience cheering)
And I like how it hugs the back.
- You like how it hugs the back?
- I like how it hugs the back
'cause like, I gotta show the waist off.
So, I like that.
Yeah.
- Yes, and on a good
day you can hug the back
and on a bad day you can take the belt off
and just let it not hug anything.
- And just let it feel like a Snuggy.
I love it.
It's nice to see you again.
- Nice to see you. Hi.
- Yeah, so I heard that you recently
made it back to "Wicked"
but you were watching it this time.
- Yes, I have never gone back to see.
But one time I went back
and my son was three and
he was so rambunctious,
he kept hitting the backseat
of the people in front of me.
So I had to leave and I wrote a letter.
- And you were like, maybe too early.
- Yes. And I wrote a letter
to the women that were in it apologizing,
because you know if they heard
that somebody had viewed...
I mean, if I left in
the middle of the show,
they would think that I...
- Oh, of course. Of course.
- Yeah.
- That's happened to me before.
Something happened in my family
and I had to leave a show,
and then, I guess it
got back to them I left,
and I was like, oh my God, it
had nothing to do with you.
- [Idina] Like you didn't like them.
- Exactly.
- Yeah
But I was there with
seven 12 year old boys,
who are all my son and
his basketball team.
His coach is actually from the east coast
and has been telling them
that they they're too west
coast, they're too soft.
They have to meet all
of the New York kids.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- So they were scrimmaging.
I brought them all on a
plane and then I was like,
where can I take them Saturday
night to a Broadway show?
Oh, "Wicked" will give me tickets.
And I took them and they were riveted.
They just sat there the whole time.
They were just so into it.
Some had seen "The Wizard
of Oz," some hadn't.
But it was just...
- [Kelly] Wait! What?
- [Idina] Yeah.
- How do you miss that as a child?
- I tried to show my son,
but he just wanted to watch
dinosaurs, or whatever.
- Oh my God.
I didn't even give mine the option.
I was like, wait, this part's real good.
- [Idina] But, it's scary.
- [Kelly] It is a little scary
- A little scary.
- Except my kids like
the scary characters.
Like my kids gravitate towards
the Ursula's or the Gaston's.
- Well now he does.
He loves scary now, for sure.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like he loves his
T-Rex's, that kind of thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Oh my God,
my kids love dinosaurs.
Both of them.
- Yeah.
- Does your son think that
you're cool generally or not?
It's kind of hard.
- Yeah, you know, he
doesn't think I'm cool.
I'm not like this.
Like I'm not allowed to say the word drip,
drippy or whatever,
because that's his word.
- What do you mean?
- He says things like,
"this is so drippy mom."
He's really into his fashion
and all his basketball.
- Is like trippy and dope, in the same?
- Kind of.
So what I'll say, he'll
come out ready for school
and be like, "whoa, that is so drippy."
He'll be like, "no, you don't get to say."
- That's my vocabulary.
- Now I've just said it
on national television.
He's gonna die.
Mom why would you say drippy?
(Kelly laughing)
I said drippy.
And then the other day,
I was going to pick him up from school
and I was too lazy to go up the stairs
to get my own sneakers,
and I'm finally in the
same size sneakers as him.
Or he's finally in the
same sneaker size as me.
And I guess he had,
I spoiled him and I got him some Yeezy's
for Christmas last year.
- Oh, Okay, yeah.
- And I was like, oh,
I've never tried these.
So I put them on and I went
and picked him up from school,
and he comes out and he goes,
"How could you wear those?"
He said, "without socks,
do you know how expensive those are?"
I was like, "yeah, that's why
I thought I could put them on
and go and pick you up from school."
- Because I bought them.
- [Idina] Yes.
- I love that he really just didn't want
you sweating in them.
Just ruining them.
- My feet are so gross!
- [Kelly] I love that.
- I changed your diaper,
but I can't put my feet in your shoes.
- Yeah, I've wiped your
butt multiple times.
Build a bridge, get over it.
So wait,
you also worked with your
sister on a children's book.
- Yeah.
- That's so exciting.
What made you wanna do that?
- Well, I don't know.
I wanted to work with my sister.
I wasn't sure about doing
another book, you know?
Like, how lots of people put
out picture books and stuff.
But the idea of doing it with my sister
who's an elementary school
teacher and a writer,
and we're super close.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it just was the
most organic experience.
- [Kelly] And you're such a
hit with kids that age too,
learning to read.
- Yeah. Yes.
- And your kids read a lot, I heard.
- Oh, Like a lot.
It's forced family fun, Idina.
- (laughing) It's forced family fun.
- Forced family fun.
I mean, now they're used to it,
but in the beginning it
was not exciting for them.
- I know.
- Well, I brought you a
very, like an early copy.
It's like the soft cover
before they've even got
the hard covers made.
But it's called "Loud Mouse"
and it's about a little
mouse with a big loud mouth,
like me.
(Idina and Kelly laughing)
- Your sister was like, I
have the perfect character.
- Yeah.
She's like this really
annoying older sister mouse,
it never shuts up.
And then there's a little...
It's kind of about that.
But yeah, it's just about
celebrating your unique gifts
and not being afraid to
share them with the world.
- Thank you for a new book.
We've gone through, literally
we read every night,
so I have such a huge children's library
and then we pass them on.
- [Idina] Oh, good. Good.
- Thank you for the new one.
If I read, like, "The Good Dinosaur"
like all these other things again...
- I love "The Good Dinosaur."
- Me too. Me too.
It's just a lot of times.
(Idina laughing)
I can, like, recite it.
- I know.
That's why I like the Richard Scarry books
because you can like...
Do you know those books?
- I don't know.
- oh, maybe I'm dating myself.
They're like before your time.
- No, they're not,
we're like the same age.
- I'm gonna get those for you now.
No, we're not the same age.
But I'm gonna get those books for you.
- [Kelly] What?
- I know, I'm 51 in like a couple days.
- What?
(audience cheering)
I just turned 40.
I thought you were literally my exact age.
What fountain are you drinking from?
- It's not. It's a lot of
makeup and people helping me.
- Congratulations.
- [Idina] Oh, thank you so much.
- I mean, on the book and all the things,
but like more on that.
- [Idina] Aww.
- Like that's great.
Congratulations.
Wait, did you say your
birthday's coming up?
- Yeah, May 30th.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's exciting.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, you get trumped by
Memorial Day every year.
That's that weekend, right?
- Yeah, I used to always.
And because it's a holiday weekend
I always was gigging and
working on that weekend.
- And even when you were young
people were probably
out with their families
for birthday parties.
- Nobody wanted, it's
a big summer weekend.
- I kind of took it
negative, your birthday.
I don't know why I did that. I don't know.
- That's okay. (laughing)
It is negative, it's 51!
- Your birthday is so awesome.
No, I literally this whole time
thought we were exactly the same.
- Well, I'm flattered.
- So you once said that the
scariest part of performing
is like the three seconds
like right before the curtains come up.
- Did I say that?
Probably.
- [Kelly] So, you do? It's amazing.
- Do you still have that kind of stuff?
- Here's the thing.
I've never been like stagefright,
or I've never had like
that kind of nerves,
but like I grew up seeing classical stuff
so you have to be perfect
in all those auditions.
- That's how I feel,
and with a theater community as well.
- You have to be perfect.
But it started taking the joy away for me.
And this one night, it was actually funny.
It was in Australia,
like this random show,
and I was miserable
because I had focused
on these minor things
that I just didn't nail, like vocally.
And then I noticed the joy of like singing
was like leaving me.
- [Idina] Leaving, uh-huh.
- Yeah. And so then, it's interesting.
I was like, you know what, like, whatever
like, I'm gonna sound like
soulful and pitchy sometimes.
It's gonna be fine, and whatever.
And I feel like my voice got better.
I feel like I became better
because you got out of your head.
- [Idina] You've got to relax.
- Yeah. But do you get that?
- Oh my God, I get so in my head
and I feel like the older I'm getting,
I'm getting a little bit more neurotic.
I don't know if that's with
success and social media,
and feeling like the lens is on me.
- But they're on you for a reason.
- Yeah, I know.
- They're not on you because you suck.
- I'm not gonna lie,
Like I just, I do.
- A lot of my friends in the
industry, they get nervous.
- But I will say that
becoming a mom helped me
because I felt the need to be perfect
was not as crazy.
- It's not the most important thing now.
- It's not.
I mean, if my son has a fever,
I'm not gonna not be with him
in the middle of the night
before I have to get up.
So then I'd get on stage
and I'd be like you screw it up tonight,
well whatever, you had to make a choice.
So if you don't hit that big
note, you know, big deal.
- That's me too. Yeah, that's me too.
But then you just alter the melody.
- [Idina] And then I was better.
- Yeah.
- [Idina] Yeah, you have
to alter the melody.
- You have to alter the
melody. You have to handle it.
My band will tell you right now,
I am the queen of walking in and going,
"oh, it's so interesting.
Are we gonna lower this?"
Are we gonna? oh yeah, just keep going.
Or like, sometimes I have to take it up.
It's just wherever your voice is.
- Exactly.
- I alter melodies, I change.
- [Idina] Me too.
- You have to if you're a live singer.
- I have a thing called
the ABC Performance.
So especially when I'm doing
like eight shows a week,
if you're really tired and stuff.
I've decided there's A show,
which is the stuff that the
composer really wants you to hit
when the critics are there.
- Yeah.
- And then you come up with
a couple alternate melodies
that no one would even
know that you changed.
But in your head psychologically,
you feel like you're failing yourself
because you're getting sick
and you think, oh I can't.
But if you just give yourself
this particular thing
and then you nail that B show or C show
in a beautiful way,
with all of your heart,
people feel just as much
and you don't feel completely devastated
that you didn't hit some high
notes for people, you know.
- Because you're human and it's a muscle,
by the by, so yeah.
But you're fabulous,
so you should always remember that.
So those three seconds,
just think of me saying you're awesome.
- I will.
That's what I was gonna say.
I was thinking 30 seconds before,
well I just imagine I'm Kelly Clarkson.
- No imagine you're you
and I'm just sitting there,
like so no matter if you suck
you're still gonna be awesome.
Just so you know.
- I'm going to think that, thank you.
- Yeah, you should think
that. I'm just saying.
So, we've all had shows that
didn't go the way we planned.
So have you ever had a show
that you were like, oh no,
like something bad happened?
- So the Menzel girls,
we have weak bladders
even before childbirth.
- Like when you pee?
I mean when you laugh.
- Like when you're jogging, laugh, yeah.
- I meant when you laugh. (laughing)
- Yes, when you pee.
And then if you're singing a lot,
you know you're drinking a lot of water.
So if something happens to
me on stage really funny
that takes me by surprise,
I just have no, there's
no... and I've peed.
And then my wonderful friend, Joby Horgan,
who is my dresser for all Broadway shows.
In "Wicked" once, I had black tights,
opaque black tights on
underneath the big gown.
I peed in them and the
tights just sapped it all up.
And then I got off stage
and I was like, Jo!
And I handed my friend,
who I love so much,
who does not deserve to take
urine filled tights to the...
- Dude, Candace is right
back here, my stylist.
Like she is laughing right now
with the things that have
happened in quick changes.
- It's so gross.
But she is my best friend
and I would do anything for her,
especially 'cause she handled
my urine stained tights.
But, and then I went back out commando,
and I sang "Defying Gravity," you know.
(audience cheering)
I was like (vocalizing).
- [Kelly] (laughing) Oh my God, my God.
That's amazing that that was the song.
Okay, so wait, you just added
another job to your resume.
We were talking about your outfit.
So Encore, what made you want to?
Are you into style?
- No, Kelly.
I am not stylish.
I'm not a fashion kind of girl.
And honestly this is out of necessity.
This is because I wanted
to design something,
and then it became a line of clothes
that I could maybe wear this
the night before tonight,
like last night.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Wear this to bed.
Then wake up, roll out of bed
- Love this line.
- Get in the car.
Do you like this line?
- Yes.
- Get in the car, get my kids to school,
get his lunchbox made, the whole thing.
- And look like you still
have your stuff together.
- And then come to Kelly
Clarkson, put on some boots.
- Some fancy boots, some red bottoms.
- And all of the fabrics
are really cozy and comfy,
and they work together well.
Because I just have super
anxiety about like...
Oh my God, this whole
show's about my anxiety.
About getting on stage.
- [Kelly] No it's not.
- But I'm just one of those people
that I get in the closet and
I'm overwhelmed by choices.
I had to, you know, wake
up early when I was little
and put my whole outfit together.
- [Kelly] I did that too.
- Yeah, so.
- Because I didn't ever care
but I just didn't wanna worry.
I have, yeah.
- Like it doesn't come easy.
You know how you have
friends that just like do it,
and they feel good,
and they'll try something and they know.
Yeah.
- Yeah, my whole glam squad
they just like wake up and
they're just like (mouth sounds).
I look, I'm like a dancer.
- [Idina] That's not me.
- I'm like what?
- So I collaborated,
and I have wonderful people on my team
that are helping me design this line
that feels really like,
it's got my New York sensibility
and my LA sensibility,
my confidence chic with my
kind of relaxed, casual vibe.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- [Idina] Oh, there we are.
- [Kelly] Oh, I like it in
the green too, that's cute.
(audience cheering)
I see a box right here, what's that?
- Oh, that's for you. Yay.
- Oh, okay.
I'm like, what is this box?
I was like, wait.
- You don't have to open it.
It's just a bunch of the clothes.
I gave you a bunch of the clothes.
- It's so heavy. You did?
- Yeah.
- Oh my God, you're so nice.
- They're good for the summer.
The new stuff for the summer.
And it's my first time out with this line
and it's just exciting.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's exciting.
- So wear it well
- I love that.
Idina's new clothing
line is called Encore.
You can look for it right now online.